I want you to panic….around the year 2030...we
will be in a position where we set off an
irreversible a chain reaction that will most
likely lead to the end of our civilization
as we know it…”
If there’s one consistent message coming
from activists and politicians pushing the
Green New Deal and massive new subsidies for
renewable energy it’s that if we don’t
take radical action now, life on Earth as
we know it will soon be irreversibly destroyed.
the world is going to end in 12 years if we
don't address climate change.
The claim is time is running out.
Science tells us that how we act or fail to
act in the next 12 years will determine the
very live-ability of our planet.
This fear-mongering is flat-out misleading,
and the findings of the scientists studying
global warming don’t support such alarmist
claims, according to the new book Apocalypse
Never.
“Please welcome Michael Shellenberger...I
know you’re an environmentalist because
you’re not wearing a tie.
okay, but you’re a new kind of environmentalist
because you’re very well coiffed.”
the book argues that deforestation and deaths
from extreme weather are actually declining,
and concerns about environmental damage from
plastics are fundamentally misplaced.
Shellenberger, who began his career as an
advocate for more government spending on wind
and solar, was eventually disillusioned after
witnessing the failure of subsidies to fix
the inherent drawbacks of renewables.
Named a “Hero of the Environment” by Time
magazine in 2008, Shellenberger is an “expert
reviewer” for the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change.
He also appeared in the 2013 documentary Pandora's
Promise, which was shown at Sundance, and
featured several prominent environmentalists
who have come around to see the virtues of
nuclear power.
it really took us getting clear about how
big the gap was between fossil fuels and renewables
for us to take a second look at nuclear.
“coal, fracking, and nukes - you’re my
kind of liberal.”
I interviewed Shellenberg over Zoom about
his new book, and why he believes that environmentalism
has become a replacement for religion in an
increasingly
secular world.